that's more than perfect thank you so
let's talk about like reading how do we
read and how the hell like how we can
help our users on internet to read
better and if I want to discuss this
topic it's because we all read like it
can be in books it can be in your couch
with a really nice atmosphere it can be
since doing a stage with vastly picture
but it's still reading or a bit less
pictures and both texts it's sometimes
about newspaper magazine just having a
really huge headache because of the news
we are also reading more and more on
screens all the kind of screens and
media and almost everywhere and that's
why I wanted to discuss with you today
reading because that's something we're
doing every day that's something that we
all are doing because even if we don't
want to you're reading advertisements in
the streets and usually we don't really
know how does it work
so hi Damien so really nice presentation
so we'll be really quick on that but my
twitter handle is I am evil oh and I
love Twitter at least I love discussing
with people on Twitter way easier than
face-to-face because in general I try
never to speak with people which is
today a bad example but like that's not
entirely true
I love discussing with people I'm just
really good at creating awkward
experiences with people really fun for
people more quad for me but you will see
that can be nice and I like just to do
some content warning so I'm using quite
a colorful language so please pardon my
french and there will be few videos
including one with really annoying sound
I'm really sensible to sound but I'm
really sorry in advance and usually my
sense of timing is really pretty pretty
bad so I will do my best to speak with
you about reading raccoons and Jack
Kurata
so buckle up it will be quite and quite
intense but let's talk about readability
and first why and the main reason why
it's because I can
I have a permit saying that I can do
what I want and today with you it will
be about a really complex cognitive
process which is readability really
complex because even if most of the
people are doing this since the youngest
age it's an acquired skill like you need
to learn to know how to read and it's
not something easy because you need
first to learn the alphabet and then you
need to learn what is this kind weird
mix of letters together that are words
you need to learn morphology orthography
semantics phonology and once you have
all of that you can start learning like
languages and the issue is that it's not
a life long skill like you can get you
can acquire reading difficulties like in
your life it's not something you will
keep like until your lecture last day
and the thing is the web is many
text-based and aside of the web being
mainly text-based add the debate on burn
on a burn but I'm sorry it will be burn
so the thing is the texts that are
composing our website that is the root
element of our website is not accessible
because not everybody can read it and
outside of reading impairments there is
one good example I'm not English speaker
in native so English for me was
something I had to learn I was in front
of a lot of website and not
understanding one word of what people
attend to me I hope that today is better
and I can hear my English and you can
understand English and not sure about
myself but we will try to see so reading
is really important and it's now also in
the way card so in the guidelines for
accessibility it's one of the success
criteria it's saying a lot of stuff
because we cog but mainly the
information here is the fact that it's
about text pacing and that's one awful
thing because if you're taking just the
accessibility guidelines and if you're
doing the CSS or the JavaScript for your
accessibility form to make your website
accessible the only thing you have to be
careful about is text pacing and
unfortunately there is a lot of studies
on dyslexia showing that we don't care
about we don't care so much about tech
spacing that's not the most important
element but still that's the only one we
can measure
so light heart space between paragraphs
space between words and space between
letters really important and before
going on CSS and the phones I just
wanted to see with you
why readability through dyslexia and one
of the reason why is because in
accessibility as usual the idea is
always to help the most impaired people
to be able to help everybody if you're
solving issues for the people having the
highest and the cap in front of some
actions you can help everybody so it's a
same with readability dyslexia is one of
the most common reading impairment it's
more or less 10% of the population
worldwide 10% of the population it's
huge and in some countries in Europe
it's even worse in a way like for
example Scandinavian languages because
of the really big amount of vowels and
like sounds in the language they are
like up to 15 to 17 percent of the
population it's really a lot and the
thing is you can try to find this like
sick child but it's not always inside
childhood too because when you learn a
new language you're facing your sounds
you're facing new things that you did
not know because not part of your first
or second or third languages and this
can trigger also some kind of dyslexia
and finally because this sixth it's not
only about reading it's about a lot of
stuff happening in your mind in your
cognitive processes mainly about
problem-solving and this is impacting a
lot of the way not only revision
internet but we just navigate so how do
we read them the first thing is the fact
that reading is not so much about the
text it's about the sounds that we make
it's about the reason that we are having
when we're speaking it's about the music
that we're creating so when we are
reading a text even just for self
we are always hearing a voice that's the
way our brain is trying to make sense of
a texts you are hearing it to understand
it to understand it and that's really
important because this voice will impact
sometimes even more than the word itself
and themselves like the feeling that you
will get from this text it will impact
the way you will understand it it will
impact a lot the way you will digest
this text so reading is mainly of
phonological process I love more than
three synapse like so phonological
basically means that it's the
association between a sound and the
meaning and that's how reading work so
basically like this when you're trying
to read there is like two different
voice in your head when trying to read
it and make it a loud one trying to
understand it and another one which is
the word around Eve trying to interrupt
all of that and if you need to create
this sound you need to take the words
and to make it a sound and for that
reading is using our eye but it's not
linear at all even if all our texts i
bet are based on lines it's not senior
at all because we're reading with a ball
like our eyes are kind of a ball so you
cannot really like move it easily with
six muscle on a line so we're doing
something called cycads so basically
when we are reading we're just jumping a
lot from places to places from group of
letters to other group of letters and
between each of the cycads we have
something called fixation so it's the
fact that we're stopping on a group of
letters before going to another one
and during this fixation it's the moment
where the reading experience is
happening so at this moment everything
is thought to be blurry around ookubo
feathers except the group of letter
itself so we are dancing like funerals
and all the shapes are round and that's
the reading moment and that's how we can
calculate the readability of a texts
usually i tracking counting the number
and length the duration of saccades and
the duration of fixation so it's less
about words that it is about staring at
screens and that's quite nice because
that's will that something we'll love to
do every day but it's like it's not real
about staring at screen it's essentially
about identifying shapes shapes of
paragraph with one more time do we care
because I hate as much as I love
despite these texts first we will like
look at the shape of a paragraph then
trying to find the different words
within the paragraph to identify more or
less what it is about and this is our
reading experience on string not linear
at all and that's why you can probably
read if despite the misspelling because
we don't care about the order of letters
we just want to recognize shapes as I
said to sound and this is happening
thanks to you letters identify features
letters
phones variable phones that's where the
link exists between the two things and
the I didn't think features it's
basically the top part and the lower
part of the word that can explain why we
can read more easily lowercase word than
uppercase and when you have mistakes
that's also why you can identify more
easily that bubble is problem and not
the awful blob of letters that is the
last one because it's about sound like
it's also like the change of letters
needs to happen in the sense that it's
part of the same syllabus it's them it's
part of the same group of sound and in
the two first ones we have the same
number of sounds that's in the last one
so that's how we can easily read text
despite installation I know it's really
early in the morning my brain hurts too
but here's something for you
I love trash pandas it's the nicest
thing ever
so what's the point of all of that the
point is like we need to design for
readability and we need also to
implement for readability and the best
way to learn it to look at airports
because they have to do that in a really
stressful environment which is a moment
where people just want to think about
the vacation just want to go in the
plane and don't want to do any
pathfinding and any game in the airports
so let's just take a look quickly at
what they're doing and the first thing
that they are doing its owning only one
phone face only one everything is
written with the same thing with the
same phone things and a series of
variations of ways this is really
helping for the like content charge and
also what they're doing it's not only
the way but it's really subtle but
they're playing with the tracking
between two letters like tteyuu is going
together so the two is way closer than B
and D for example so still one phone
face a series of different font wave and
different tracking and you can find this
consistency in the background with C Phi
which is also really close and way
closer that would be a C and E together
for example so basically that's what
they're doing it's readable it's
efficient that's great but can we do
better because it's static it's great it
works its efficient but it's not working
for everybody
first you need to speak English that's
something you need at least recognize
letters and numbers but also it's not
adapted to everybody some people don't
like the contrast between yellow and
black because it's really aggressive
it's one of the highest contrast you can
find great for readability not so great
for autistic people so some autistic
people so great but not cast
so can we do better ah the sound is not
there sorry
so yes I'm sorry
and yes we did because that's basically
what happened with with variable phones
it's not only we can do it like there is
now a way to do that with only one file
so variable font will help you doing
will help you do the extra mile and
doing like all the effort to go from
just offering a readable experience for
everybody to offering a way to customize
the experience for people and this is
important because accessibility is
really really really really hard and if
it's really hard because it's something
that you will never manage to do
entirely you cannot create a fully 100%
accessible solution like you have to do
at some moment choices between solutions
because not everybody's learned not
everything is compatible and because
there is no one fits all solution the
only way to be accessible if you do
customization and the creation of
accessible and inclusive experience is
something quite interesting because it's
about people quite interesting but it's
also about collaboration and
customization collaboration because
first we need to collaborate with our
users we need to understand their needs
we need to know that what we're doing is
meaningful for them but also because it
can help creating a lot of collaboration
between designers and engineers
everybody wants to do accessible on
accessible web like I never heard
someone saying yeah no I don't want to
like I don't care okay I don't care I've
heard it but nobody wants to do this on
purpose like being like I want to create
an inaccessible interface so usually the
gap between yeah I'm really interested
and I'm making accessible websites it's
not so much about skills because you can
learn
on internet it's more about discussions
on collaboration you need first to share
the same language between designers and
engineers because language is a really
root element to reality the best way to
share common reality between people is
to share some language and designers and
engineers don't really know anymore how
to discuss together but variable phones
can be a solution for that and also it's
a good way to customize experiences for
our users and to offer them the way to
do what they need to do to be
comfortable with what you're offering
and reading is really about this because
we have different we all have different
capabilities some people can read like a
whole book during the whole day without
any break just reading reading reading
reading reading if I'm starting reading
a book in 15 minutes I'm doing five
other stuff every time newspaper books
whatever I'm just doing five other stuff
at the same time so we all have
different capabilities attention span
but we also have different media that we
that we appreciate some people will only
read on screens if it's about with a Inc
for example like Amazon Kindle and all
kind of stuff other people really want a
book some people don't care it's like
different app ability is different media
and because we're all not read in the
same way so sorry medium sorry all the
website forcing you to read a lot of
content in one uniform way there is no
standard standard like readable
experiences and that's something you can
find in all the products in the markets
that you can like that you can use to
read some contents I have a really
strong hate for a MP but that's also
because while creating the web next to
the web there is medium trying to
recreate that this kind of like package
of readability like it's supposed to be
readable but not for everybody
there is solutions that will take the
content and offer it to you in a way
that is a bit more customizable and
that's sometimes it's quite nice because
you can at least find what you're more
comfortable with and there is
RSS feeds the website themselves and
assistive technologies that will adapt
entirely the content that you're
offering to the needs of the users and
basically variable phones will bring you
all over there with like the
customization possible for your products
and in a way if you have to see it this
way
it's basically viable phones are moving
more and more from the experimentation
stage to offering the same kind of
experience that we have with a font size
to go from size to girl are a bad idea
by the way just so so you we can stop
doing this because browsers can do that
and it's not the case with variable
phones like you cannot rely entirely on
browsers to do that because it's really
dependent on the fonts that you chose
and what are the different capabilities
so thanks for asking
Damian how do we implement such a thing
like should we give complete freedom to
our users and as usual when someone is
asking should we give complete freedom
to our users hell no hell no no no no no
never never never never never with
what's happening in here I'm a freedom
so viable like viable phones what is the
variable part of a viable phones the
variable part is in fact for access and
it looks like CSS and all the modern
capabilities really love access so here
we have like one which is maybe best
known so the weight of a font and here
you can play like with sorry with weight
and a value be like we'll value after
it's not revolutionary but it's quite
nice because the main difference is like
two main difference are first you have
only one file quite nice for performance
quite nice optimization but also you can
do really nice transitions there is no
jump from one state to the other there
is a really smooth
transition because it's based on vector
and you can easily go from one to the
other so wait the second one is width
and for this one it's something that
people love to play with in InDesign
that it can be really awful for the
readability but at the same time really
nice because you can basically expand
the weight of a letter but still keeping
something which is consistent which is
still designed to be like expanded in a
specific way even when it's really
condensed it's still readable I would
not advise going this condensed but
still it's readable and only working
with CSS and the same working with
transitions Roman versus italic but
please don't do Italy first because
readability is really impaired with
italic and also because usually most of
like most of the really cheap fonts that
we will find don't have a real italic
tetris-like slant the folks but quite
nice view too just for the optimization
part only one file during doing the
Roman and the italic here just no
transition and the last one because we
always need the last one you can slant
you can do some some slant like you can
change the the angle like the Dom the
degree of the fonts you can already do
that with rotation of each character
which is a pain but here the good thing
is that the baseline stay the same so
characters until are more and more
slanted but the line is still the same
so same here working with vectors really
nice for transitions and all of that is
working with one line of CSS which is
really not so difficult and in project
doing for example like projecting react
with style components assuming that we
can offer a full customization easily
thanks to this kind of solution based on
changing the value with JavaScript
so these are the foxes but as usual I
love adding a bit of bonus so there is a
bonus one it's not really an access but
kind of so it's the optical size the
optical size is a concept in in
topography which is really important we
completely lost it in font files in the
web we recreated it with having a lot of
different variation of font weight and
declaration in CSS and changing the
classes changing the declaration but now
we can do this just from a phone file
which means that the fonts can be only
one font again and fully adapted to what
we want the user to experience so this
can be really a great game changer for
the way we are loading phones and the
way we are doing performance because
only one file loading a bit of
everything
subsetting can be nice in this case to
not load everything but still one file
and you can set within this file a
variety of presets
preset like this so the optical size
it's a mix of everything it's the fact
that you can change the way you can
change like the space of characters you
can change how they behave we can change
the body of it you can change the sign
you can choose everything because
everything is based on vector and the
idea is the fact that the type designer
will set breakpoints like will CSS and
at specific breakpoints we will have a
different position for the vectors and
we can move easily from one to the other
and that's how we can recreate the kind
of layout that we have in magazine for
example because this is already existing
in CSS a lot it's in design system it's
what we call usually like the different
text variations bodies small tags
caption legend like all these kind of
things are different creative ways to
create different optical sights like if
we see the one made by Shopify supplies
as a design system you find it here
there is display small there is body
there is subheading
and all of that relying on only one font
so now thanks to this kind of
capabilities we can go from one font
with one star per different font way to
one song and one compile and that's
mainly for me how we can recreate
accessibility like features with this
kind of solutions for like with web
fonts like it's it's basically the best
way we can have now to propose an
experience where we can have like some
switcher some way to customize we can
let people going from one process to
another process like to have something a
bit like more build something a bit more
like with more ascendant with Madison we
can work on that and thanks to that
there is one linked bonus it's the same
more less but it's what it's offering us
it's offering us to define also custom
access optical size is what at the
beginning one custom acts so that's why
it's a bit linked but this can also
allow you to work with the designers to
create for example a variation for
dyslexic people because open dyslexic
open dyslexia is definitely not a
solution
in the sense of offering just this as a
relative is not working for this texting
people because it's targeting only a
really small part of the sexy people
they need to have like this kind of
optimization but you can just create
like a lot of different custom access
defined with four-letter tags and in
this case in accessibility you can ask
tech designers or you can try to work
with the type that you were designed
like that you were working with and
trying to merge all the phone together
like all the phone files together in
only one by working on three main axes
the first one is the asunder and des
under length the second one is the ball
size and the last one is the ball shape
so basically what does this it means
that you can change easily the length of
the the southern part and the a southern
part that also the weight of it and this
can reel
be helpful if you want to make the
experience more readable but you can
also play with the thickness of the ball
so on the B side although the main core
part of the letter and something you can
play with and that's the best way
usually for typefaces to be more
readable because if you make it if you
make the body a bit heavier and if you
make the most of the weight of it on the
baseline it's a good way for people to
make the difference between a b.a.p
energy especially if you also offer the
the idea of having a bit more lengthy
ascendant and ascendant because in this
case there is absolutely no confusion
between what's going up and what's going
down and you can play with almost any of
the variation so you can easily with
only one file move from like the regular
text that you would have to the one on
the top
same for serif versus Sun serif because
it's entirely based on vector it can
only be just a variation with the
optical size that you move from one to
the other and optical size are working
with like font size so you just have to
set for each font size which one do you
want to use we're gonna take another
crack at Whitman coming in there like
five times what are you gonna do annoy
him into talking haha
so I hope that I was not doing this with
you like just shouting for like almost
30 minutes in you hear this kind of
information because you can experiment
quite easily and you can have a better
success than Jack Peralta in this scene
and the way to experiment is basically
doing this like there is a fault that
you can use doing this and the variation
of the font size is helping to move
other font weight is helping to move the
horse for example but you can also do
this kind of things which are way more
useful because accessibility is not only
about how do we read but it can also be
about what is the thing that we get from
the texts for example like with
different text here we can have a
different feeling a feeling of anxiety
and we could also try to reduce anxiety
by providing different variation of
fonts so people can reduce the wave and
the emotional width of a font size for
example so these are the kind of changes
that you can do with only one file you
can also do color changes so if you have
like a website of or brand that are
using all full color that are not
accessible you can also rely on this to
change the branding and the logo first
of all the font in the logo to another
color based automatically on different
choices I know it's easier to change a
level but it's cool and one of the last
example it's this one it's the website
of a typography web typography
conference called unperson and all of
this is only one font file which in the
end is really amazing because the last
argument for one font file next
performance is it's only one from fair
to replace so all the people that rely
on replacing specific and main font file
in style sheets for accessibility reason
it means only one file replaced in these
websites to get a correct experience if
you cannot read the text over there so
Indian 3-3 small information if you're
really interested by experimentation in
variable phones I would really advise
you to follow
Davidge Jonathan Ross amazing type
designer doing a subscription model for
almost nothing and every month are
getting a new typeface that you can
experiment with but also what BBC
experimentation were because they played
a lot with this and that created some
really nice try and experiences on
variable fonts also on subtitles to see
how it can help making subtitles more
efficient and to visit V fonts calm
which is a listing of all the variable
forms that you can use at the moment
like bold well-known and access praxis
which is just a website giving you a lot
of information on in the end how does it
work
so one fun filter will demo so I hope
that you're ready to implement that and
thank you
[Applause]